das hat man megabau also werde ich hatte
in der aufnahme so richtig muffensausen
und ist auf jeden fall so lang geworden
leute
wir haben richtig richtig zerstört das
kann ich schon mal so
servus und heute besprechen wir ein
thema am herzen liegt sozusagen sie an
der seele liegt aber dass wir eine [ __ ]
sind formulierung gewesen dass wir
verzichten wir darauf und heute sind mit
dabei der logo und der wäre place war
natürlich der beschreibung und
lebensfreude das neue projekt nämlich
minecraft legend die anderen beiden sind
ja auch dabei bei der truppe stimmt man
kurz ok danke sind ja auch beide dabei
immer cook management und können daher
gut mitreden und wie ihr vielleicht
wisst haben wir heute schon eine
aufnahme
und ja ich will euch also kurz ein
bisschen erzählen wie das bisher war und
natürlich details zu verraten wird nicht
foltern viel er will ich euch hier ein
bisschen ja also bisschen man kann ja
sozusagen auch sagen du erklärst du
erstmal das projekt weil filialen more
heute wäre auch inka brannte das war ja
gar nicht in den winkel du idiot
damit wäre mehr punktuell i met your
mother sein logo ist sie tot waren 32
zweierteam gegen unterliederbach leute
ich habe zwar schon die beschreibung von
dem trailer gepackt minecraft legend ist
alter ist es ein riesen timo mein gott
oh mein gott comline 2006 gesagt ist das
ein riesenthema alter hast keine chance
dort gleich so ein richtig kleiner leute
gegen so ein quatsch
ich sage es jetzt gerade mal kurz wie
werden wir in der andere hunde join
minecraft legend ist ein team battle wir
im konzern heißt erwin wir spielen auf
sg vier objekte geschaffen
vier grad nein es hat nicht mehr
gereicht wird bereiten gleiche panel
schade
das spiel war so nett es ist ein team
pvp in zweiter kann man kann sagen es
ist ausgelegt vivaro noah nur ist es
halt so sein eigenes motto
es hat ein eigenes motto und es hat eine
andere lebens regelung also es ist schon
deutlich unterschiedlich und zwar hat
jedes team drei leben mit jemandem warte
warte ein kurzer form möchte ich noch
anmerken das team battle zuvor war
natürlich klar also mein halt wenn man
bei dem wetter jetzt machte ist es halt
so war er war halt ein team etwas
besonders viel erfolg hatte aber die gab
es davor auch schon und es gab auch
dieses gebiet also ein vorläufer von
makrov legend weil gleich auch schon vor
ware oder so ne na.de migration auf
jeden fall dieses format gab schon davor
also bin ich das irgendwie leute sagen
mikrofon übrigens ich habe jeden
einzelnen später wird ein bisschen der
mensch machen also den ersten gold jetzt
muss ich wieder ewig hinterher laufen
ist nervt mich so immer diese verfolge
reihe
es ist immer dass das ist nah gut 331
ohne diese posten 33 und hleb leute wäre
es für mich auf jeden fall liebe ich ein
dreierteam tag wird in dem zweierteam
erlaubt spielmodus team erlaubt ist sind
so viele tipps erlaubnis ist nicht
vergeblich die feuerwehr hat mal einer
in den kommentaren eine stimme nicht
dann ist es jetzt mein teams erlaubt
kannst du immer noch 22
rockland ich muss mal kurz das
rüberbringen was ich rüberbringen wollte
und zwar wie gesagt ein battle von 515
zweierteams und jedes team hat drei
leben wenn die leben des teams auf null
fallen dürfen die mitglieder nicht
möglich bauen jedes mal wenn ein
teammitglied stirbt egal wie optisch
mops dich lass dich gegner keine ahnung
für die das tier mein leben so und wenn
die leben auf null sind das heißt wenn
ein drama gestorben ist dann darf der
darf der relativ steil dann nicht mehr
dann nicht mehr nicht mehr response und
es ist aber möglich sich leben dazu zu
verdienen und zwar indem man gegnerische
teams tötet
für jeden toten gegner den man umgelegt
hat kriegt man ein halbes leben dazu das
heißt beispielsweise wenn das eigene
team keine leben er hat aber man selbst
noch am leben ist
aber ich mehr respawn dürfte dann kann
man zwei gegner töten um sich ein leben
zu verdienen und seine eigene team
fallengelassen und ich bereite mich
gerade mit diesem typen baum macht es
eigentlich geht aber das ist halt dann
auch die sache wasser dann richtig den
teamgeist wieder fordern und das macht
richtig spannend weil man später dann
halt nicht alleine sondern für das team
einerseits hat man megawatt also werde
ich hatte in der aufnahme so richtig
muffensausen geworden wir haben richtig
richtig zerstört das kann ich schon mal
sagen und am morgen wenn dieses video
seht morgen freitag zehnter zehnter
kommt die erste folge kurz nach 18 uhr
und dann werdet ihr sehen was passiert
ist schaut euch auf jeden fall an das
war richtig richtig krass und es wird
ein geiles projekt das verspreche ich
euch
wir werden viel spaß haben ja und ja ich
find's einfach googeln so jetzt
irgendwas was ihr noch ergänzen würde so
zum projekt als beschreibung also was
ich generell noch hinzuzufügen hätte ist
dass die leute den teaser irgendwie
falsch verstanden haben
es ist ja nun tigers ist kein richtiger
trailer wir schreiben auch irgendwie
allen in den kommentaren höhe was das
für ein trailer im titel steht ein
teaser und dieser ist nicht gleich ein
trainer ich ganz ehrlich bin
das geil ist ja dass vier sekunden
später da konnte ich den gar nicht
angucken
ich habe das video freigeschaltet
sekunden später kam das kommentar sei
das projekt aber der trailer aus scheiße
der konnte sich das video geht
vielleicht zehn sekunden und erst direkt
noch vier sekunden online drauf
geschrieben
aber wenn ich ehrlich bin so der trainer
sei zwar ohne ich jetzt so der berner
er ist auch nichts was soll man machen
projekt selbst ist richtig heftig
und ich kann nur jedem empfehlen
schaltet morgen eines extrem geil
es sind viele große youtube youtube
dabei und viele die ich noch nie erlebt
habe ich denke mal ich lebe mich nicht
zu weit aus dem fenster wenn ich sage
dass ich meine ersten folge ein richtig
großen youtuber gekillt habe
und ich wollte das ist dann schaut als
regent logo und wer wisse schon was ist
wenn ihr wissen wollt dann schaltet
morgen am 10 10 1 kurz vor 18 uhr kommt
die folge und es wird ich hab so was
überhaupt schon aufgefallen dass in
meinem namen zwar mag re steht ist
einfach der grießbrei aus dem kreis
bringt ist einfach der kreml da bist du
ein genie ohne witz kommt zum glas ich
mochte schon hier links rechts richtig
und ein neues dazu
danke danke danke danke danke danke zum
findet denke alle die das noch nicht
wussten bisher ich bin in dem zweierteam
mit logo hier und wer ihm ist im
konkurrierten zweierteam mit passiven
dem baron und das können wir sagen auf
der genau gegenüberliegenden seite ich
glaube das ist das letzte das wir uns
begegnen werden weil wenn wir so
geradeaus zur mitte schauen es wäre um
genau auf der anderen seite ich meine
wäre ich aber echt leute die ich zum
beispiel als ich selber schon schon zum
pvp aber halt ich schaue nicht so diese
hat prinz papa und ich muss schon sagen
wenn ich da ist zum beispiel so basti
sie also von kompetenz der gigaset ag
ja ich denke mal schon hat er uns auch
da der vor allem ohne mich jetzt aus
einem fenster zu den so farbe und mich
da richtig wächst reifen bei der hat so
die straight combo die
also die superstars können schon krass
treffen und china ich weiß nicht was so
realistisch wie mein gott es gehe ihr
habt ihr ja dann freilich aber was ist
einfach so in der art rautenberg treffen
aber es wartet ihr verhalten team
euskatel profi schlecht ok kriegs krimis
ist tot leute als ich wollte am ende
noch mal kurz sagen so bisschen an
dieser version projekt drin ist mister
morgen mysterien urlaub ist drin ist
drin von annie art dann ist weiß weiß
natürlich drin ist amor richtig schweres
thema ich wette nur dumme und mit dem
organisierten krasses team also ich
freue mich auf jeden fall gegen die
ganzen teams anzutreten und wäre mieste
recken leute wirklich gefallen hat und
ihr durch darauf heute schaltet morgen 1
18 uhr ich kann euch nur empfehlen
lassen daumen nach oben da ihr könnt
gerne die beiden checken die in der
beschreibung dann sehen wie es morgen
wieder mit der ersten folge
mycroft legend